you're a good person before i leave the
house i look up and i go the same
spirit or whatever that protects me you
know how protects my family my friends
today you know somebody don't come up to
what comes up to the car and smacks you
you don't know you listen
you're in the car with your [ __ ]
music and you're listening to a podcast
some [ __ ] uh isis could come right up
to you and stab you in the [ __ ] neck
right there you never [ __ ] know
let me give some shout outs here real
quick
mel pryor from new zealand you bad
[ __ ] james redshaw brandy lynn
i'm gonna call you this week don't [ __ ]
around russ zatagou whatever your
[ __ ] name is john wolfe josh thompson
and frank newson i love you [ __ ]
what's up with you what do you got on
your mind oh [ __ ] we forgot about some
little tony benefit he [ __ ] up the
national plays 150 years we didn't
mention the uh we're not going nowhere
okay
i wanna be around oh [ __ ]
to
pick up the pieces
when
somebody breaks your heart are you
kidding me or what
break out the heroin [ __ ] it's a
new week what do you want to do you want
to be a [ __ ] follower and have that
bushy mustache
i see that [ __ ] bushy mustache on
guys i'm going to beat somebody up you
know that jerkball from that tv show had
the bushy mustache what's his name parks
and rec yeah you like him what's his
name i don't know his name he's a funny
guy that bush
is funny in 10 years when you're sucking
dicks that's the bush that's going to
tickle isis's dick
you [ __ ] [ __ ] half a fruit what do
you like get your little fake glasses
and your mustache everybody's got the
old man glasses now with the fake
mustache that hangs over the lip so when
you get ready to suck some arab
terrorist dick
that's the bush well they call that the
shag that's a [ __ ] shag you [ __ ]
idiot's got be yourself stop being a
[ __ ] sheep all your life that's the
reason why there's [ __ ] isis and
these terrorists you're the first ones
gonna be sucking dick in 10 years you
[ __ ] copycat [ __ ] have an
identity be a [ __ ] man these [ __ ]
[ __ ] i go out on i go out to
hollywood to do con i see 10 guys in a
circle four of them had the exact same
look
and i looked at them with the old man
glasses like they're old they're [ __ ]
20. they're old man another bushy
mustache like they're licking it like a
[ __ ] uh and then four of them are
standing like your mustache is not cool
really yeah
are you [ __ ] kidding me no wonder
isis is setting up remember when he is
russians will be [ __ ] in the ass too
you [ __ ] followers remember we went
to the comedy store and like the
newspaper stand had the sinatra hats all
like
jesus christ just in case i gotta put up
what they call those sinatra hats what
do you call them i don't know there's a
name
for dory everybody's got a fedora now
some skinny guy with [ __ ] no sleeves
on his shirt with tattoos or fedora i'm
[ __ ] impressed get the [ __ ] out of
here so